what's going on guys this is rob and it
is monday so it's time for another
episode of we need to talk about
whatever and in this instance we're
doing we need to talk about gore the god
butcher from thor 4. but before we get
into that right one of the things that i
do want to address here is the notion of
comic book accuracy because admittedly
for all you guys out there who have been
torn up and i mean like you're losing
sleep you're on social media just just
tweeting out a firestorm you know
because you're so upset that gore has or
doesn't have head tentacles and and has
like a nose and that kind of stuff i've
been busting your balls and honestly
i've kind of had fun doing it to be
honest with you guys but let's actually
have a discussion here right the reality
here is that when it comes to characters
insofar as their physical representation
from comic books being adapted into
films i don't really care and i haven't
for a long time like back when the first
x-men movie came out sure it mattered to
me but like that was years ago and i've
long since grown out of that if you look
for example or if i look at a character
like hugh jackman as wolverine he's not
comic book accurate right wolverine in
the comics is like five and some change
he's really really short and he's just
really really stalky right just like
this huge bulky guy like he's not by any
standard of measurement anything close
to what hugh jackman looks like as
wolverine but i still love hugh jackman
as wolverine so this idea that things
have to be perfectly comic book accurate
to me is is nonsense what's most
important when it comes to characters
being adapted from
comic books into like films and tv shows
is the nature of the character right
like what is it that made that character
who they are in the comics that you
translate over that's what's significant
because at the end of the day it's never
really the physical appearance of a
character that defines them that makes
them recognizable but it doesn't really
define them there are precious few
exceptions to that being the case
spider-man superman batman a few like
that but by and large for most
characters that exist out there if you
change the way they look it would still
essentially be the same as long as the
character's form and function remained
the same that i think was lost with the
character of gore in thor four one of
the things to know is that in the comics
gore this guy is an absolute demon right
there's no redeeming qualities about
this guy right he's not like anakin
skywalker in star wars where like he
sees the error of his ways at the end
and says tell your sister you were right
and he goes back to the light side that
doesn't happen here right that does not
happen with gore in the comics this guy
cannot be redeemed he doesn't get fixed
there's no things go back to being okay
and the guy sees the area of his ways
and everything's soft there there is
nothing like that for gore i mean for
god's sake there's a point in the comics
when he becomes a universe i mean
literally like the motivation of gore
like this this guy's viewpoint was so
extreme the whole idea behind gore is he
wanted to construct something called the
god bomb where he would basically
detonate it in the time stream and it
would kill every god that ever has
currently does or will ever exist
throughout all of time in the universe
now obviously that's an exact plot
they're not going to copy over into the
film because one it's just overly
complicated and two it would seem a
little nonsensical to the average
movie-going person and then three they
wanted to expand on the existing
cosmology of gods and cosmic entities
and all that kind of stuff hence the
nature of eternity as it was introduced
to us but the thing about this is that
gore as he exists in the film does not
feel like gore and he's not really
relatable in the same way that gore was
in the comics in the comics one of the
reasons why people loved the character
of gore so much is because the way his
story was told was tragic it was a
tragic story right in the comics this
guy lost his mom he lost his wife he
lost his kids he literally lost
everything that mattered to him in his
life because he lived on a really
desolate world and his people were a
nomadic tribe that were highly religious
and they would pray to their gods and
goddesses and they would rarely ever
answer right they would almost never
answer that it was one of those things
where gore questioned the existence of
all the beings in existence right all
the gods that were out there because if
something great happened his people
would say well it's because the gods
wanted us to have this great thing right
food water resources and so on but if
they go days or weeks or months without
finding water or food or anything like
that and people in their tribe were
dying of like dehydration starvation the
the elements and so on then the answer
was well it's because the gods are
testing us we're not praying enough or
something like that and so once gore had
finally snapped and was like there are
no gods right there are no gods out
there if there were gods we wouldn't be
living in this crappy place and he was
booted from his own people then he
stumbled across basically the body of
knoll and one of the golden gods that
had felt null and he realized that gods
existed then he was vengeful he was
angry and that's why he went on the
conquest that he went on because it was
one of those things where you could read
those stories and say how many bad
circumstances have you endured in your
life and you were told well god has a
plan right god has a plan for all of us
like how many times have you whether you
come from a person who's a religious
convictions or not have you been offered
that explanation by someone somewhere
and your knee-jerk reaction is if god
really had a plan and if god really
loved us would things really be this
crappy either god's not real or god's a
dick that's your response right that's
like your knee-jerk emotional reaction
that was gore's reaction and so a lot of
people could really understand his
visceral response to the circumstance
that he was in and then waging a war
against gods across the cosmos and
killing them all now it wasn't just to
have that kind of relatable element gore
was a badass i mean it was it was one
thing for him to be like i've discovered
this magical sword and now i'm gonna
kill every god i can find and he dies on
his first attempt it's one thing to do
that it's another for this guy to just
continually grow powerful and to
actually do it and to see him wreck thor
three times and then to see thor from
three different eras all of them teaming
up right like young thor present day
thor and all father thor teaming up and
still not being able to beat this guy
and it took thor from the modern era
wielding two mjolnirs and the all black
himself to defeat gore and then
eventually gore came back anyway because
loki when he killed everybody on earth
ended up setting gore free like it's
it's it's that level of just badassery
right that i wouldn't go as far as to
say that gore as a villain in terms of
his original depiction was on par with
thanos maybe he was maybe he wasn't we
never saw the two of them fight there's
no reason to believe he wasn't but at
the same time the fact that he couldn't
necessarily kill thor he could only
really overpower thor is an indication
that he wasn't really on the same level
of like strength and danger as like
thanos because thanos could easily kill
thor i mean like easily right like it
would not be difficult for him to do but
beyond like the physical attributes and
his fighting stance and the the clear
and present danger that he represented
in terms of like death and destruction
in terms of him as like a character just
being like driven by rage motivation
this unstoppable conviction oh he was
very much like thanos and i think in the
movie that was a hugely missed
opportunity and i think it has been for
some time i understand that the marvel
cinematic universe doesn't want
everything to feel like thanos they
don't want every villain to feel like
thanos but i think that thanos was one
of those rare instances in the marvel
cinematic universe when they actually
got a villain right when it was like
damn this villain's really really cool
and he's really really interesting he's
kind of an idiot but like he's still
cool and interesting in some ways and i
think that ever since then it's kind of
fallen short the reality here is gore is
not a villain that i would have put into
a comedic thor movie i never would have
done that because even though gore as he
was portrayed by christian bale which
christian bale did a great job even
though gore is a highly dangerous
villain and was shown to us you know in
the film as being a very serious villain
that needs to be taken seriously the the
comedic nature of the film overshadowed
that and so whether it was the intention
of the marvel cinematic universe or not
in a lot of ways i had a hard time
taking gore seriously i had a hard time
looking at that and saying damn dude
gore is just going to kill everybody you
kind of knew it but you didn't really
believe it you know what i mean i mean
you saw him like kill a god and so it's
like okay so like this guy's a threat
kind of i guess but what would have
really really made this guy more
impactful is if it had a kind of
infinity war slash in-game feel to it
not in the sense of grandiosity you
don't really need gore to be in a movie
where like the avengers are teaming up
to defeat him he's not really that big
of a threat he's a thor story i'm sorry
a thor character he's a thor villain and
he needs to stay that way it needs to be
one of these things because the
relationship between thor and gore is
very personal because it's literally a
battle of a guy who denies the value of
gods versus a man who is a god himself
and in fact if you read jason aaron's
run on thor and you read like the whole
gore saga in its entirety literally thor
starts to realize the value of of the
role he plays and the fact that like he
really has just ignored people out there
who were praying to him it's like the
one thing you never see in thor comics
like you've never really seen an
instance when thor is like someone's
praying to me for aid i should stop what
i'm doing and impart my help on them or
a portion of my power or something like
that but when you got to that jason
there and run you realize yeah thor
really is a god and there are people who
pray to thor but he never acknowledges
them that was really the idea that like
gore was right there was a point in nick
fury which is why nitwi thor lost the
ability to wield his hammer is the basis
behind all of that so the relationship
between the two is very significant i
would not have put gore in some team-up
film but i would have made the film
serious i would have made it a pretty
serious and a pretty dark and heavy film
right that it wouldn't be some kind of
ragnarok event where it feels like
everything is coming to an end but the
film would have been a serious
introspection on the character of thor
where he basically ends up questioning
everything about himself and is he
really a god in any real measurable
sense because now you've got someone
like gore who steps up and says people
like me pray to people like you and
people like you ignore people like me
and again sure that was the message that
was being conveyed in the film but the
comedic nature of the film took away
from the significance of that and that's
why i say a film's tone is everything
the tone of a movie is everything
imagine if you will if we got that if
thor 4 was not a comedic film if thor 4
felt like avengers in game or infinity
war where it had a couple humorous
elements here in there but it was the
almost total opposite of what it was in
as it was presented to us imagine how
that would have changed the way you saw
gore the other thing that i didn't
necessarily like about this is it felt
like taika wati and these guys wrote
themselves into a hole with the
character of gore and i think if
anything gore is just just another
instance another reminder of how the
marvel cinematic universe does not know
how to handle villains they don't know
what to do with their villains you know
i gather the stories about the heroes or
whatever but i i will say from now until
the day i die that the villains are
almost always more interesting than the
heroes they are almost always more
intriguing than the heroes there they
have a better backstory usually that
backstory is more tragic it makes them
more relatable but gore like so many
other villains that came before him
right going all the way back to iron man
1 and obadiah stain that he's just kind
of a guy that's there to push the plot
forward to say here's what thor is doing
and then he basically dies at the end
it's a waste it's a colossal waste and
it feels like gore was wasted in his
entirety in this movie that there's no
reason why over the course of this film
we should have had anything other than
the feeling there is a better than fair
chance that odin's son is going to die
like thor odin's son is gonna die like
that's just there's no way to walk away
from that and then when we get to the
film and he doesn't die and it's not
done as some macguffin right an eternity
wishing box but it's not not something
along those lines that were actually
surprised like holy cow he made it out
of this in one piece i never expected
that to happen right that gore almost
appears as this overwhelming force him
traveling the cosmos killing god after
god after god and that's the thing in
the comics you didn't necessarily see
gore killing all these gods but it was
the conversations he had with thor and
how easily he was able to overcome thor
that gave you the gravity of what it was
that was going on right that thor is
showing up to these locations where
these gods had just been massacred where
it was gore telling thor i tortured the
god of torture to the point that he
actually gave up his own family or
really it was a god of torture but he's
like i tortured a god that represents
the concept of torture the very essence
of torture could not hold up to me
that's the that's where i'm at right now
right this person this is or this being
that is beyond redemption that can't be
saved that can't be fixed right that in
a lot of ways imbues the statement of
alfred from the dark knight when he says
some people out there aren't looking for
anything like money or power they can't
be bought bullied or reasoned with some
people just want to watch the world burn
that's what gore should have felt like
and he didn't instead gore felt like
just a guy who was there who was doing
some things and he was pretty dangerous
but at the end of the day you knew he
wasn't gonna make it you know and and
again that's what makes things so
heartbreaking is because i don't care
about how he looks it doesn't matter to
me how he looks gore could have been
three feet tall in varying shades of
pink and it wouldn't have made any
difference to me right he could have
looked like majin buu from from the
dragon ball series it would have been
fine it wouldn't have mattered what
mattered the most to me was the the
depiction of gore the danger he
represented and how significant a threat
he was and it just didn't feel that way
so with that being said guys we're going
to bring this to an end let me know what
you guys think about gore down in the
comments section right let me know how
you guys felt about his character again
i'm not really hating on thor 4 i get
it's the popular thing to do right now
right it's the trend to hate on the
movie i didn't think it was a terrible
movie it was not bad you know it wasn't
like thor 2 right it wasn't nearly that
bad i just think this this movie
highlighted more than most marvel
cinematic universe movies do that they
had a villain who was great and they
didn't quite know what to do with him
and ultimately wasted him they didn't
truly understand how valuable of a
villain they had and the significance of
what it would mean if they got rid of
him and didn't bring him back in any
measurable way or didn't do him justice
in the first place so again we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace